[Música]
llegó el momento de directo hay por eso
Vamos hasta Centroamérica en Nicaragua
la persecución contra la Iglesia
Católica continúa la justicia
nicaragüense condenó recientemente a un
grupo de siete religiosos a 10 años de
cárcel los integrantes de la Iglesia
Católica son acusados por cargos
relacionados con traición a la patria
conectamos con nuestro corresponsal para
Centroamérica Andrés Suárez Jaramillo
Andrés muy buenas noches cuéntenos qué
detalles se conocen sobre los motivos
para condenar a estos siete religiosos
de la Iglesia Católica en Nicaragua
Andrés muy buenas noches estos siete
religiosos condenados a diez años de
prisión eran los acompañantes de
monseñor Rolando Álvarez El prelado de
mayor alto rango de la Iglesia Católica
de Nicaragua en haber sido arrestado
durante el régimen de Ortega y Murillo
un episodio que ocurrió el pasado 19 de
agosto de 2022 el mismo día en que Fue
capturado el obispo Álvarez fueron
también arrestados estos siete
religiosos cuatro sacerdotes dos
seminaristas un laico que es un
reportero gráfico de la diócesis de
matagalpa y ellos corrieron otra suerte
del obispo porque fueron llevados
directamente a la cárcel el chipote
donde están confinados la mayoría de los
opositores del gobierno de Ortega
mientras que al obispo Álvarez le fue
conferido el beneficio de arresto
domiciliario el pasado 26 de enero la
justicia sandinista resolvió entonces
declarar los culpables por el delito de
traición a la patria que se entiende por
haber menos la integridad del estado y
también por haber difundido noticias
falsas a través de las redes sociales lo
que ahora Les costó una condena de 10
años de cárcel el centro nicaragüense de
los Derechos Humanos calificó esta
decisión de arbitraria y también de una
aberración jurídica Mientras que el
Vaticano y la Iglesia Católica
internacional aún no se ha pronunciado
Andrés cómo está el panorama de la
denominada persecución religiosa que se
le atribuye al gobierno de Daniel Ortega
y Rosario Murillo en contra de la
iglesia católica
está por verse que sucederá justamente
con monseñor Rolando Álvarez como había
dicho es el prelado de mayor alto rango
de la Iglesia Católica el único Obispo
en haber sido capturado puesto en el
resto domiciliario en la historia de
Nicaragua él enfrentará un juicio el
próximo 28 de marzo para responder por
los mismos delitos por los que fueron
condenados estos siete religiosos sin
embargo se sabe que el desde el gobierno
de Ortega se le ofreció el destierro a
cambio de la libertad es decir sacarlo
de Nicaragua Pero él se negó y por tanto
el juicio se ha dilatado y se encuentra
en un limbo Y es que hablando de
destierro esta fue la suerte que corrió
otro monseñor Rodrigo Urbina el pasado
27 de enero fíjense ustedes él se
encontraba en el aeropuerto de Miami
justo antes de abortar el avión rumbo a
su natal Nicaragua
los funcionarios de la aerolínea le
dijeron que no podía abordarlo porque le
habían prohibido el ingreso Es decir
desde las autoridades nicaragüenses se
le había impedido el paso y como él
entonces son otros 15 religiosos los que
se encuentran o bien desterrados o bien
en el exilio sobre todo porque ellos han
sido los grandes denunciantes de las
violaciones a los derechos humanos en
Nicaragua